what exactly is mom's new job she's an
advocate for superheroes but I thought
superheroes were still illegal so things
haven't spiraled out of control the
moment I left looks normal to me I'll be
there
it's up to us
hey little baby these eggs are see
incredible Stu yep she gets down green
PG
did you wash your hands with soap did
you dry them I did so are we going to
talk about it what the elephant in the
room
what elephant moms new job
to make some wrong things right
hell they bring supers back into the
sunlight
to change people's perceptions about
superheroes and Elastigirl is our best
plan better than me I watch the kids no
problem
not the way you're supposed to do it dad
they want us to do little no that way
why would they change man everything's
great
[Music]
he's in excellent health is freaky you
know it's crazy right to help my family
I gotta leave it to finish the law I
gotta break it you've got two kids can
have that choice
[Music]
combustion imminent what does that mean
it means fire Robert
the screen Slayer interrupts this
program for an important announced it
might get weird I'll be the ASA
[Music]
you